she faced bankruptcy before becoming a
successful speaker and best-selling
author her TEDx talk how to stop
screwing yourself over has over fifty
million views on YouTube alone she's
best known for her best-selling book the
five-second rule she's not Robinson
here's my take on her top ten roses
success vol ten enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one use the five-second rule so the
five-second rule is a self coaching tool
that's all that it is and it's something
that I invented literally 20 feet from
here in my bedroom although that bedroom
wasn't built back then it was something
that I invented to beat my habit of
hitting the snooze button hmm and the
way that it works is very simple the
moment that you need to do something and
you can feel yourself hesitating and you
can feel the excuses rolling in count
backwards to yourself 5 4 3 2 1 and
something weird will happen the moment
you get to one you'll actually move and
I invented it by mistake I invented it
during I think the worst moment of my
life which was 2008 Chris and I my
husband of 22 years we were about to
lose everything
well his restaurant business was going
under I had just been fired from a job
my first job in the media business so I
was just wallowing and self-doubt
because I thought boy have I really
screwed up I had changed my career
taking a risk gone into the media
business it didn't work out I felt like
a total loser I felt like I made a big
mistake we had three children mortgage
to pay the entire house had been used to
leverage the business so it our life
savings so at the kid's college savings
I mean just on the verge of losing it
all Chris was sleeping on the couch and
I just couldn't get out of bed and so I
invented this thing the five-second rule
one night when I saw a rocket ship fly
across a television screen at the end of
a commercial and it gave me this idea
and the idea was hmm I wonder if I
launched myself out of bed so fast
I wonder if I could move fast enough
that I could beat the self-doubt and
anxiety that I felt every single morning
when I would wake up and it was really
that dumb and that simple of an idea and
for whatever reason when the alarm went
off that next morning what happened is
what happens to all of us all day long
inspiration strikes so the alarm goes
off and used the thus knew who use the
alarm clock as a metaphor for those
moments when you know you should do
something and the alarm goes off and
what's interesting is most of us don't
have a problem with what we need to do
it's how we make ourselves do this
that's hard so the alarm went off and
immediately my mind woke up and my mind
started spinning as our minds do and I
started immediately thinking like most
of us do when the alarm goes off I don't
want to get up on is you know it's cold
I don't want to give the face a day I'm
an employee and then the body starts to
kind of get a little tense when anxiety
comes in or you start to feel
overwhelmed about this you got to deal
with and I felt myself reaching for the
snooze alarm like I always did but that
morning I went 5 4 3 2 1 and by the time
I hit one I was standing up and I was
kind of freaked out because why would
something so simple work but I went on
with my day and I used it the next
morning and the next morning or the next
morning and then I started to wonder god
I see that it works as a cheat for the
alarm clock but I wonder if it could
work for other things so I started to
use it for every moment in my life where
I knew what to do but I didn't feel like
it 5 4 3 2 1
literally just decimates any excuse that
you have and as I started to use it in
my life - 5 4 3 2 1
not be an [ __ ] - Chris 5 4 3 2 1 turn
and walk away from the Bourbon and not
have a drink 5 4 3 2 1 pick up the phone
and network 5 4 3 2 1 walk out the door
and go to the gym everything changed
because my decisions changed rule number
2 own your dreams you know what my dream
was my dream
someday was to be a talk-show host and I
was always embarrassed to admit it
because it seemed so implausible I mean
it seemed how on earth doesn't want to
even do that and see that's the the
thing about dreams is that your dreams
they matter and in order to achieve them
you're going to have to be able to have
the courage to be brave enough to
actually state what your dreams are
because if you can't own them you don't
deserve them rule number three don't
make busyness a habit let me talk to you
about Dan so Dan was the first person
and take control that I coached and he
is a super successful guy he loves what
he's doing right now he is I think the
world's best phys ed teacher he's a
total pro at it he loves his students
he's been doing it a long time but he is
starting to panic about the next chapter
of his life he's starting to panic about
the fact that you know time is ticking
and I love what I do but I'm not sure
this is my true calling how do I figure
it out how do I make sure that I don't
wake up at the age of 70 or 80 or 90 and
realize that I never actually went for
the thing that I really love and a lot
of times going for the thing that you
really love doesn't mean quitting your
job
it means figuring out how to be more
focused and deliberate in your life so
that you can start to add in incremental
progress every day on inching forward
that side hustle that passion project
that book you've always wanted to write
and so one of the first takeaways from
Dan's coaching session one of the first
takeaways is busyness and we take a look
at the fact that yeah there are a lot of
you that are really busy because you got
a lot going on and then there is the
type of busyness that we keep in our
lives because by being busy you
convinced yourself that you're in
control by being busy you
fill up your life so much that you also
also have an excuse for never ever ever
having the time to do the thing that
scares you which is to write the book
start that passion project work on your
side hustle and so you got to be very
careful if you're somebody who feels
like you're busy all the time to
understand that busyness can become a
habit and busyness can become your
biggest excuse rule number four discover
your passion
the problem with passion is that you and
I have bought into this massive fantasy
world where we think that passion is a
person or a place or a thing that
somehow like a needle in a stay has a
needle in a haystack that you are
somehow just going to stumble into the
thing and you're gonna find that one
person or you're gonna find that one
thing that you're meant to do or you're
gonna find that career and honestly we
got to change the way that you think
about passion and purpose before you
will actually be able to bring it into
your life
because the truth is passion isn't in a
person
it isn't in a place and it isn't in a
thing it's something inside of you and
when you flip the definition of what
passion is and when you actually
understand what you're looking for when
you say I want to discover my passion
then you'll be able to create more of it
in your life if you want to learn how to
have more confidence check out my 254
series they're free the links to join
are in the description below if you
didn't give us what anybody else thought
what's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life I know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this do you really
because you can make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
rule number five make energizing
decisions people can smell a phony a
million miles away
and what will make you successful is
following the thing that naturally
energizes you because it's unique to you
yeah and when your energy is expansive
you will naturally attract people that
want that same feeling yeah it's really
that simple it doesn't feel that simple
when you're stuck I get there and I can
sit here and say it's that simple
but I'm 27 years into the trajectory of
figuring it out but hell I wish I had
known this when I was anything yeah I
would have saved myself a world of hurt
rule number six takes small actions
every day the one person that is
diminishing your ability to make these
dreams a reality is you because when you
state your dream this is what happens
you state it and then all of a sudden
your present - how far away you are from
it and when you see the distance between
where you are and where you want to go
the direction that your dream requires
you to walk in you're gonna get present
to the gap and that scares us
that's where fear comes into play and
you start to think of all the reasons
why you don't deserve it you start to
think of all the reasons why you can't
do it all that you have to do in order
to start to pursue your dreams is take
small actions every day that align your
life in that direction so what does that
mean if you want to play guitar
professionally it means that you start
playing guitar more it means that you
sign up for open mic nights it means
that you go back to classic if that's
something that interests you you see
your dreams will happen either because
of you or in spite of you they don't
happen because of other people they
happen because of you and what you do
the second you have the bravery to state
that dream now are you going to create
it or are you going to diminish it
your mind rule number seven roll with
the punches those of us that are out
there in the world doing big things that
one of the reasons why we're able to do
big things is because we have trained
ourselves to just push forward even when
things are not the way that you want
them to be going to keep your cool to
roll with the punches even when you
don't have the support that you need and
so you know I had something happen
yesterday I was in the middle of giving
a speech so imagine this you're on stage
you are twenty minutes into your speech
you have 40 more minutes to go you have
30 more slides to go to which is what
was happening at that point and all of a
sudden my laptop dies I mean just blank
you guys so I've got an entire audience
I'm through the first third of my speech
I have two-thirds of the speech to go
and my speech is a story that has a ton
of videos and photos in it and my laptop
died and what had happened is the AV
team had plugged the laptop into a
podium that had no power in it so my
laptop was set up correctly it was
plugged in but it was plugged into
something that had absolutely no power
source so over the course of the hour
before the tech check - when I was on
the stage the laptop has run out of
juice and so all of a sudden Here I am
completely cold laptop I just you know
had this moment where I thought the
first thing in my mind was holy cow what
am I going to do for the next 40 minutes
and I could feel my stomach start to go
crazy and the butterflies to kick in and
it just wow I was I was extremely
panicked for about a second and then I
was like okay use the tools use the
tools don't don't get nervous get
excited because you can show everybody
what looks like in front of a live
audience to have a massive
technical breakdown and not lose your
cool and so I made a joke about it the
a/v team ran up I said look you guys
have no power here so take it back there
get it plugged in and I'll talk for two
or three minutes while you get this
thing set up now meanwhile I'm thinking
while I'm talking to a live audience
what if they don't get the set up what
am I gonna do how am I gonna fill the 40
minutes when the whole speech is not
only anchored in the story but it's
anchored in all of these photographs and
proof of people's stories from around
the world and so I'm like don't panic
don't panic use the tools now and then
all of a sudden the guy shouts out
what's your password you know because my
my screen was locked so then I thought
okay we're gonna get this done not a
problem it took about five minutes for
things to get back up and running and it
was one of the longer five-minute
periods of my life but I got through it
and one of the reasons why I got through
it is because I've trained myself to
roll with the punches that's what I've
trained myself to do rule number eight
feel the fear and do it anyways
Heather is held back at work because
what happens is when she has to have a
really difficult conversation when
there's something that she wants to talk
to her boss about when there's a
conflict with one of her colleagues you
ever have a conflict with your
colleagues at work ever feel like you
work in a toxic work environment well
this is something that you need to
understand sometimes the toxicity in
your work environment is about the other
people and sometimes the toxicity in
your work environment or in your life
environment or your friend environment
is about stored memories in your body
from your childhood I know it's crazy
stuff because the saying feel the fear
and do it anyway it's true because your
body feels situations that set you that
puts you in a state of being afraid
before your mind catches up and starts
thinking about what you're afraid of and
so one of the key takeaways from take
control and one of the things that I
want to teach you today is that if you
start to tune in to your body and you
start to notice the
signals that your body is sending to you
in your day to day life signals like
butterflies in your stomach signals like
feeling a rush of energy up to your neck
signals like your armpits sweating
signals like your hands getting sweaty
signals that your body is stepping and
noticing a situation that reminds it of
your past learning how to read those
signals that oh my god here goes my body
my body is starting to recognize that
this is a situation that puts me on edge
recognising those signals first and
slowing the body response down before
your brain starts to go oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god that is a
critical skill in taking control of your
life
rule number 9 be real everything we talk
about has to be proven right everything
I love that I don't give you some
[ __ ] I've read in a book or
something that I've read on Instagram
the only things that we share are things
that are backed by science that have
been researched that we have seen
working in our own lives that we see
working for our audience and I think
that is critical because let's face it
anybody can put up a inspirational quote
you know that they've read from somebody
else anybody can tell you to you know be
positive or do this or put in the work
or hustle or whatever the hell it may be
at the end of the day it's just talk
yeah you have to know how yeah and I
also am you know somebody who is a
little bit cynical so you know I'm sort
of embarrassed that I'm in self-help on
some level cuz he sounds stupid right
you know I mean I come from i I mean I
I'm older than you I'm almost 50 self
have had a really bad name you know 20
years ago and I also AM Ivy League yeah
lawyer yeah and I am an entrepreneur
there's a lot of [ __ ] I mean there's
a lot of there's a lot of fake yeah sure
I I had are renting houses in Rory's be
telling you if you use their click final
strategy or whatever
that you'll be rich like they are and
yeah you may and chase the money if it
energizes you there but there's a lot of
smoke in there I'm real number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip is slowed down for many of us
slowing down is really scary but that's
exactly what you need to do and so if
you are always in a rush if you feel
like there's urgency in your life if you
move at a pace that makes you feel
panicked or rush you've got a million
things to do and you think that you're
busy but you're not productive the
solution is not doing more it's doing
less it's not speeding up it's actually
slowing down because being busy doesn't
mean you're in control it means you're
being driven by this fear of slowing
down you're being driven by the fear
that when you slow down you're gonna
have to confront where you're at and
you're gonna have to start doing the
work and that be can be scary but you
take control of your life not by
speeding up everybody but by slowing
down you take control of your life by
removing distraction and adding in focus
you take control of your life by being
honest with yourself about the things
that you're filling your life with it
doesn't matter that makes you so busy
and that also prevents you from finding
the 15 minutes that you need every day
to really find the courage to focus on
making your life a little bit better or
pushing something forward if you're
somebody who's guilty of being busy and
never having the time to do the thing
that really matters to you that your
hearts calling you to do or you never
have the time to do something to take
care of yourself I want you to find 15
minutes today and I want you to slow
down
whether you've always thought about
meditating and you've never done it
download the combat listen do it do one
guided meditation go for a walk for 15
minutes just to quiet walk without your
phone or with your phone turned off have
a cup of tea or a cup of top coffee and
read something listen to a podcast for
15 minutes
take a bath tonight something where you
experienced the sensation of slowing
down because again busyness becomes a
habit and when it becomes a habit it
becomes an epidemic and when it becomes
an epidemic it will rob you
of your ability to take control of your
life and at the root cause of all of
this is fear just the fear of slowing
down because when you slow down and you
start to create priorities and you start
to take control now you're responsible
for what's happening in your life and
you can no longer rely on just
complaining that you're busy now I've
got a special bonus clip from Mel on how
to change your life that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watch the video to
taking action here we go question number
one where do you need to just roll with
the punches number two what small action
can you take every day this week and
number three where has busyness become a
habit that you need to eliminate I think
the most important thing I want you to
know is whatever it is that you're
dealing with right now no matter how
scary it is no matter how overwhelming
it is or even if you're just bored with
where your life is or if you're super
happy I want you to know that you always
have the power to change your life
because you have the power to make a
decision to change how you think about
something to change how you treat the
people around you to draw boundaries and
to make the small changes that add up to
absolutely everything
if you want more Mel Robbins check out
the top fifty rules video made on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if you are somebody that is
sitting around waiting for some external
force to come and do the work for you
that is such a losing bet